>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert Newlen: Good
morning, everyone,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
It's good to see so
many people here today.
Our program today is a continuation
of our Congressional
conversation series
in which the library invites current
and former members of Congress
to discuss their careers
in public service.
It's a real honor and
privilege for me
to welcome Representative
Jackie Speier today
and to welcome her to the Library.
Representative Speier has
had a distinguished career
in public service, from her
time as a Congressional staffer,
as a state legislator, and her
current role as member of Congress.
She represents the 14th District
of California in the House.
Everyone knows where that is --
San Francisco area,
absolutely beautiful.
She is the ranking member on the
House Armed Services Subcommittee
on Oversight and Investigations
and also serves
on the House Permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence.
Among the issues that she has
focused on: Ending sexual assault
in the military; gender pay equity;
consumer protection; cybersecurity;
and student loan affordability.
Representative Speier has
a fascinating personal
and professional story
to share with us.
She's overcome adversity
numerous times in her life
and channeled those
experiences into an impressive
and distinguished career
in government service.
Our conversation today will
be led by Colleen Shogan,
the Deputy Director of our National
and International Outreach
Service Unit here at the Library.
Colleen is a political
scientist by training
and a self-described
lover of Congress.
I also want to commend to
you this wonderful book,
which Represent Speier co-authored.
I think you'll all
appreciate this title:
This is Not the Life I Ordered.
This is a great book to
keep right at your desk
when you're having
those bad moments.
I've already consulted
it several times.
So it's my pleasure to
welcome Representative Speier.
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen Shogan: Terrific.
Good morning and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I think we're going to have a great
conversation here this morning.
At the conclusion of our
conversation back and forth,
Representative Speier is happy to
take questions from the audience.
But I'm going to kick us off.
So you were interested in politics
at a young age, but you didn't grow
up in a particularly
political family.
For your confirmation you
chose the name Jacqueline
because of Jackie Kennedy.
So can you tell us at a younger
age what got you interested
in politics and public service?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: I came
from a very blue collar family --
first in my family to go to college.
Not politically active,
as you pointed out.
I guess I was 10, 11, 12 years
old during the Camelot Era
of the Kennedy Administration.
And I think everyone in the country
was uplifted by this young couple
who had taken Washington by storm
and the sense of hope and aspiration
that was, I think, so
vividly there and palpable.
And so I guess that's
what first drew me in.
And then I did take the name
Jacqueline at the confirmation.
I hated the name Karen because
my mother would always yell Karen
and it would just drive me nuts.
So I took Jacqueline
as a confirmation name.
And then I when from a
public elementary school
to a Catholic girl's
high school by choice,
which was another interesting
point in my life.
And so I was meeting a
whole new group of students.
And so I just decided that I
was going to take my nickname
at that point and make it Jackie.
That's how that involved.
In terms of politics I think I
just remember reading the local
newspapers and I was drawn to
this local mayor, who was young --
Leo Ryan, mayor of
South San Francisco --
who then ran for the state
assembly and got elected.
And there's a plan for all us.
And we don't always know the plan.
But I'm 16 years of age; my parents
get a solicitation in the mail
for Assemblyman Ryan's reelection.
I take it, fill it out, say I have
no money but I would volunteer.
And then Saturday morning my
job was to vacuum the house.
And so I'm vacuuming the
house and the phone rings.
The vacuum cleaner's still going.
I hear this voice on
the other end saying,
"Would you come to be interviewed?"
And it was Leo Ryan.
And he was having a campaign
meeting at his home in Millbrea.
And I went up and was interviewed.
And they were actually
interviewing young women
to be what they called
that year Ryan Girls.
And there's a picture of me
in my office as a Ryan Girl.
And it was at the height
of the Beatles.
So we all had boots, black
tights, little miniskirts,
a little kind of British hat on.
And we went around the
communities just campaigning
for then Assemblyman Leo Ryan.
And that's how it all started.
>> Colleen Shogan: And you continued
to work for Leo Ryan when you went
to UC Davis and as you were going
to law school as well in California.
Can you tell us a little
bit about Leo Ryan?
He had a unique view of his
job as a representative.
He became your political mentor.
So can you talk to us a little
bit about what Leo Ryan was like?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: So he was --
I always said he ate
bureaucrats for lunch.
He had this inquisitive sense
of wanting to know more.
And he was, you know, a teacher by
profession, so he taught history
and government and English.
And he, you know, told me that
I didn't know how to write
when he read my paper in college.
And it was actually a critical
analysis of his operation.
And I had gotten an A-minus on it.
He crossed the A-minus out and put
C-minus and said I didn't know how
to write and he was
going to teach me.
But he also had this sense
of being experiential.
Because he had a healthy
sense of skepticism,
he wanted to do things himself.
So after the riots in Los
Angeles, he went down there
and taught school there for a week.
He wanted to look at the criminal
justice system in California,
so he put himself in Folsom
Prison for a week to evaluate that
and actually wrote a play
based on his experience there
that never got published.
But so he had by his very core this
sense of wanting to see firsthand.
There was nothing like being
there as opposed to listening
to some advisor tell you
about a particular issue.
>> Colleen Shogan: When you were
working for Congressman Ryan
as a senior legal counsel
after you had graduated,
after you had earned
your law degree,
in 1978 Congressman Ryan decided
that he would lead a delegation
to Guyana to visit the
Peoples Temple commune
that Jim Jones had
assembled in Guyana.
And you were a senior part of his
Congressional staff at that time.
Can you tell us about the
decision that Congressman Ryan made
to actually lead this delegation?
Why did he decide to go to
visit Jonestown and knowing
that it was a dangerous --
could be a dangerous trip?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier:
Well, first of all,
I don't think he thought
it was dangerous.
He presumed that he had
a Congressional shield,
that that would somehow protect him.
Mind you, there were no military
escorts that joined us on that trip.
He had had a friend whose son had
been involved in the Peoples Temple
who was mysteriously
killed at a railroad tracks.
We had a number of
constituents in the San Mateo part
of the district whose young
adult kids got involved
in the Peoples Temple.
It was a huge church
in San Francisco.
Jim Jones was very politically
active and connected and served both
on the human rights commission
and then on the housing authority.
So had it wired there.
There was a group of family
members that came about concerned
about loved ones in Jonestown.
There was a couple who had
been part of the Peoples Temple
who had their son who
was still in Jonestown
that they wanted to get out.
And so this all kind
of came together.
We have lots of meetings.
There was a member of the
Peoples Temple who had fled
through the embassy in
Georgetown, Guyana and come back
to San Francisco that we
interviewed who talked about all
of these horrendous activities
going on -- the sexual assault,
the physical assault, the gun
running, the mind control.
So it was on that basis -- he was
chairing a subcommittee on oversight
of American citizens abroad -- that
he decided that he was going to do
like he did before, and that
was to go see firsthand.
>> Colleen Shogan: So you traveled
to Guyana, and you did get to go
to Jonestown to see the
Peoples Temple commune.
You were there for a number
of days and there was unrest.
And there was even an
assassination attempt
on Congressman Ryan's
life while you were there.
And it was decided there
was some people maybe wanted
to leave Jonestown,
there was defectors.
And it was decided that you
would vacate, that you would head
to the airstrip and
there would be planes
that would be there
to transport you.
And when you were there, there
was an ambush from people
from the Peoples Temple,
actually, and they shot
and killed Congressman Ryan
along with four other people
and severely wounded
you in the process.
Since it was such a remote
airstrip, you actually stayed there
for 22 hours without medical
attention or really any help.
So can you take us back
to that day and talk to us
about what you were
thinking when that happened
and how this affected
your future career path
and your future career
in public service?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: So just
to take you back a little bit,
we were in the commune
for about 20, 24 hours,
maybe a little bit less than that.
We got there, we had a tour.
We started meeting
with family members.
There was really a script that
they were basically all reading
in their minds.
And it was, you know, pretty
obvious that there was mind control.
One of the reporters who was on
the trip, Don Harris from NBC,
was walking around the perimeter
of the pavilion smoking a cigarette
and two people slipped him notes.
That's the first indication we
had that people wanted to leave.
So we were there overnight.
The next morning I retrieved
them and their belongings,
and then word spread and more
and more people wanted to leave.
And then it became clear
that we didn't have
enough room in the plane.
So we were going to
do the first air lift
and I was going to leave with them.
And Congressman Ryan was going to
stay behind with probably another 40
or 50 people that wanted to leave.
There was then the
knifing attempt on him.
The truck was about to leave.
We stopped, he got into the
truck, we went to the airstrip.
Unbeknownst to us, there was a
tractor-trailer following behind us
with seven gunmen on it.
I'm coaxing a little Guyanese
child out of the airplane
because he had scampered up into it.
And we didn't have
enough seats as it was.
So I was trying to coax him
out so I could put people
on the plane -- on the two planes.
And all of a sudden
this noise broke out.
And at first, I had no
understanding of what it was.
People ran into the bush.
Congressman Ryan ran
under the plane.
And so I followed suit and
hid underneath a wheel.
They came and they had ID'd
who they wanted to kill.
And so they shot us
at point-blank range.
Congressman Ryan was shot 45 times.
And you could be helpful to me
because I always say I think he's
the only Congressman in the history
of this country who's been
assassinated in the line of duty.
But I've never been able
to absolutely confirm it.
>> Colleen Shogan: That's,
I think, true, actually.
Because I remember when I worked
at CRS this was an inquiry
that we had, that we worked on.
So I actually remember that.
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Okay.
All right.
And I was lying there, playing
dead and was shot five times.
The whole right side of
my body was blown up.
And I looked down and there was
a bone shooting out of my arm
and my leg was totally blown up.
And so what happens in a
moment like that is that you --
you know, you're in
shock, of course.
But it was almost like
my mind was telling me
that half my body was good and half
my body wasn't, and I was just going
to ignore the half of my body
that, you know, wasn't relevant.
I was lying there and
literally what do you do
when you think you're dying?
I mean, I thought,
"My God, this is it.
I'm 28 years old.
This is it.
I'm not going to live to be 85.
I'm not going to get
married and have 2.5 kids
and live happily ever after.
This is it."
So I was raised as a
good Catholic girl.
And the first thing I did
was say the act of contrition
and literally waited for
the lights to go out.
And when they didn't, my grandmother
who is in her mid 80's kind
of flashed in front of me.
And she was this powerful
matriarch in my family.
And I said, "I'm not
going to have her live
through my funeral
if I can avoid it."
So I kind of dragged my body
to the cargo hold of the plane
because the engines
were still running.
And one of the reporters actually
from the Washington Post came
up behind me and said,
"Hurry up, Jackie."
I can't. So he shoves
me into the cargo hold.
And the plane wasn't going anywhere.
There were bullet holes through
the engine and one of the wheels.
And eventually they took
me out of the plane,
put me on the side of the airstrip.
Unfortunately, it was
on an ant hill.
But you don't sweat the small
stuff when you're dying.
So one of the reporters had a tape
recorder nearby, and I asked him
if I could leave a
message for my parents.
And so I tape recorded a message to
my parents and kind of a last will.
And then was on that airstrip for
22 hours without medical attention.
There was a tent nearby,
so they put me in the tent.
And through the night the producer
for the NBC affiliate would come
over to the tent because they were
now at a bar in Matthew's Ridge.
He would bring a bottle of rum --
Guyanese rum -- for
me to take swigs of.
And it was very potent,
Guyanese rum.
So that's how I got
through the night.
But it was those moments
that I decided if I survived,
I would never take a
never day for granted,
and that I would live every
day as fully as possible,
and that I would commit
my life to public service.
And so that was kind of one
of those defining moments.
And it really provided
me an extraordinary gift
because at a very young
age I learned
that there were no tomorrows --
no tomorrows were guaranteed --
and how precious every moment was.
And once you've almost died,
you're not afraid nearly as much
to do things that others
might see as a little risky.
>> Colleen Shogan: As you
recovered, you decided to run
for Congressman Ryan's seat.
And you didn't win the primary,
but you quickly pivoted after that
and ran for a local supervisor's
election and you did win that seat.
And you went on to have a very
distinguished career in local
and state politics serving in
the California legislature,
both in the assembly
and also in the Senate.
Can you talk to us about your
time in local and state politics?
What lessons did you learn in state
and local politics that prepared you
to be a member of Congress?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: I think the
lessons I learned really stemmed
from Congressman Ryan.
I mean, just not being
afraid to go after something.
And I remember one of
the first issues I dealt
with was a local utility had
a transformer that spewed
out PCB's in someone's backyard.
And they said, "Oh, no,
this is not a problem."
And I took them on.
It was Pacific Gas & Electric.
It's no small utility, right?
Ironically, I'd have another
experience with them more recently.
And so, you know, I learned
early on that you can go
up against very powerful
interests and succeed.
So it was, you know, a lesson
that has held me in good stead.
And you know, I like slaying
dragons or at least trying to.
>> Colleen Shogan: In 2007 --
we are the Library of Congress,
so we like to talk about books.
So in 2007 you published this book,
This is Not the Life I
Ordered with three other women.
Can you tell us the story of this
book, why did you write this book
and how did you come to write
it with three of your friends?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: So this
book was five years in the making.
A group of friends and I would
get together once a month
to help each other,
to support each other.
We'd all gone through
traumatic experiences.
I had lost my husband in
an automobile accident
when I was pregnant with
our second child 14 years
after Guyana happened.
And I'd always thought everyone
gets their fair share of grief,
but then that happened and it
was incredibly devastating.
So we would get together
and have lunch.
And the rationale for getting
together every month was
that we were going to write a book.
We never put pen to paper
for the first four years
and then eventually
did and wrote the book.
And it became a -- and we told
stories, not just our own but those
of other women who had gone
through very difficult times.
And it became kind of a how-to
book of how do you get through it?
What are the tips?
You know, creating a
gratitude journal was one
of the tips that we suggested.
And the first day it may be
only that your dog didn't pee
in the carpet, but, you know, the
next day it may be something else.
And we also suggested that what
we had created was really key
to our being able to survive.
And that was what we
called kitchen table.
So getting a group
of people together
as a kitchen table
that would support you.
And that's the only reason it
exists, is just to be together.
And I've noticed in my life that I
have a number of groups like that.
I have -- we created a married
widows club after I lost my husband
and then a friend lost her husband.
And she's actually one of
the co-authors of the book.
And so over the years
there's been about 14 of us.
No one wants to join
this particular club.
But it has been a great
source of support.
And then I have my yoga girlfriends.
And for the longest time
we actually did yoga,
and now we just kind of
go on trips together.
[ Laughter ]
>> Colleen Shogan: In 2008 you ran
for Congress again;
this time you won.
You represent the home district
where it all started from
and the same district that
Congressman Ryan once represented.
You're a member of
the minority party
in the House of Representatives.
You're a Democrat.
Tell us about what motivates
your service to Congress.
You're the member of a minority
party in a majoritarian institution.
The House runs by --
typically by majority rules.
So what motivates your
service when serving
in an institution that's not
incredibly popular these days?
But you love it.
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Yes,
I'm part of the 10% or 11%
that John McCain talks about.
So the backdrop here is that I spent
18 years in the state legislature
in California and had
300 bills signed into law
by mostly Republican governors.
So I come here wide eyed and
bushy tailed thinking I'm going
to take all I've learned in the
state legislature and apply it here,
except there's a lot
of differences, right?
You introduce a bill and you
can dust it off every two
or three years, but it's not
necessarily ever going to be heard.
That wasn't the case in California.
Every bill got heard.
Seniority here is as important
as being in the majority,
that you really have
to wait your turn.
And it is a very hierarchical
environment.
And since I've been here,
we have been in the
minority most of the time.
The first two years I
was in the majority,
didn't know how lucky I had it.
So I would say that I'm an
optimist and I have the belief
that we will be in
the majority again
and that we will be
able to do good work.
And I think my job now
being in the minority is
to say the emperor has no clothes
when the emperor has no clothes,
to be that voice that
calls our colleagues
out when they're not speaking on
behalf of the American people.
I brought some slides to show you.
Maybe this is a good
time to do that?
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
Well, I'd like to talk
about your approach to some
of your House floor speeches,
which is a bit unusual these days.
A lot of times members come to the
House floor, they use talking points
that are provided to
them by your party.
But you have a different approach
when you talk on the House floor;
you draw from personal experience,
you're not afraid necessarily
to call out perceived
double standards practiced
by some of your colleagues.
So tell us a little
bit about your style.
Is this sort of spontaneous when
you go on the floor and you decide
to make these types of speeches?
And how has your frank rhetoric
-- has it had an impact?
Have you seen an effect
by your approach?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: I
so first realized the power
of the floor one night
when we were debating.
The Republicans had just
taken over in the House.
And the very first bill
they introduced was H.R. 1,
which was to defund Planned
Parenthood to the tune
of $400 million or $500 million.
And we were sitting on the floor.
It was late in the evening.
And I was going to get up
and speak on the hypocrisy
of somehow defunding
Planned Parenthood
because one clerk misspoke at
a Planned Parenthood office
and somehow that was
reason to defund it.
Meanwhile, Halliburton had
bribed foreign countries
and was still getting billion-dollar
contracts from the US government.
So that's what I was
going to talk about.
The member right before me on the
Republican side started reading
from a book about second
term abortions.
And he talked about
the sawing off of legs.
And I thought, "Oh my God.
How can he be talking like this?"
So I kind of threw away my script
so to speak and ended up talking
about a second term abortion I had.
And I remember finishing
and trembling.
And then John Lewis came up to
me and he had tears in his eyes.
And he said, "Jackie that's the
most powerful speech I've ever heard
on the floor."
Well, coming from John Lewis,
you can imagine how I felt.
He said, "It reminded me of
when my aunt was living with us.
And one day she walked down the
stairs in a blood-stained gown.
My mother took her to the hospital
and she never came home again."
And then, of course,
it took off virally.
And I realized for the first
time the power of the floor.
And as I got into the issue of
sexual assault in the military,
I started telling stories of men and
women who were sexually assaulted
in the military whose lives
had been totally destroyed.
So that's how it first evolved.
And then I recognized that, you
know, you can bore people to death
with what you say on the House floor
or you can try and have an impact.
So these are some of the slides
we're going to show you now.
I do want to say at the
outset I can't begin
to tell you how important
your service is to all
of us as members of Congress.
I've had many of you come in over
the years to brief me on issues,
and what you do on our
behalf is really priceless.
So I'm sure you are here
because you believe in Congress
and love Congress and are doing
it for all the right reasons.
And I just want to give
you a shout out for being
so very good at what you do.
Okay. So let's start.
This is -- is this a
chamber of Congress
or is this a doctor's office?
And I actually wore a white
doctor's coat onto the House floor
to make that particular speech.
>> Colleen Shogan:
And these were props
that you have in your [inaudible].
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Yes.
>> Colleen Shogan:
These were next to you?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Right.
I'm big on doing posters.
This was done -- I was very outraged
when Ray Rice and Ray McDonald --
both big football players
-- were not, you know,
taken out of the games
once it was disclosed
that they had committed
domestic violence.
And so this was an effort to try
and get some public
engagement on that issue.
And the point was, you
know, put them on the bench.
Whenever someone is charged
with sexual harassment
or domestic violence, I mean,
they basically are sidelined.
You know, they either fire typically
or if you're a police officer
and there's undue force
used in a crime,
potentially you're put
on administrative leave.
And that's what I was just
suggesting with that one.
This was a floor speech because
the Republicans had decided
to sue President Obama because
of the Affordable Care Act.
So my point was there
was no standing.
It's taxpayer money being wasted.
It was useless, it was a political
stunt, it was inconsistent,
it was a distraction,
and it was also stupid.
This one I actually haven't
done on the House floor yet.
But I was pretty outraged when
Burger King decided it was going
to invert and join with
Tim Horton in Canada.
So I actually had an amendment
to the National Defense
Authorization Act so require
that any company that
inverts could not continue
to have a government contract.
Burger King has 187
installations at military bases
across not just the United
States but all over the world.
And, you know, they get free
space, free electricity.
I don't think they pay
for the employees there.
It's just, you know,
a great boondoggle.
And here they are, they're
renouncing for all intents
and purposes their US citizenship
so to speak and inverting.
So this is a Whopper.
And you probably can't see it there,
but it shows the amount of money
that the -- I think it's
something like $356 million
in subsidized services that
taxpayers pay because they pay
such low wages, their
offshore profits,
avoiding paying US capital
gains -- $82 million --
and avoiding paying foreign
earnings tax, $275 million.
So the total is $1.6 billion.
Now, ironically that amendment
was in the NDAA last year on box.
So it wasn't going to be taken up
until one of the members pulled it
and said, "Well, wait a minute.
This is legal."
And so it got taken out and
we ended up not putting it in.
So they're continuing to
run their Burger Kings
on military installations.
This was another one from last year.
They decided they were
going after the sage grouse
and the lesser prairie chicken
and take them off the
endangered species list.
And it has no basis in the
National Defense Authorization Act.
So we decided that we'd mock it
a little bit on the House floor.
And so there's an RPG on
that lesser prairie chicken,
and we're commenting on the
national security threat that it is.
I've got very talented
staff members [inaudible].
And this we've started doing.
I was particularly incensed.
I mean, I'm a victim
of gun violence.
I know what it's like to
survive and, you know,
overcome the trauma
associated with it.
That doesn't begin to deal with
those who die and the family members
who are left to somehow put
their lives back together again.
And so these moments of silence
on the House floor had just got
to the point where I
couldn't take it anymore.
And I actually walked out.
And the LA Times
reporter happened to see me.
And I said, "You know,
this is hypocritical.
You have a moment of silence
and then you're silent."
And it's only these high
celebrity almost shootings
that we do a moment of silence.
So I've started to go onto the
House floor every month and talk
about each and every person who's
been murdered in a mass shooting.
Now, a mass shoot is
four or more people
that have been injured or killed.
And these are the pictures
of those who were victims
of mass shootings in April.
And you can't necessarily
tell it because some
of them are individual pictures,
but the number of families
that get gunned down
is extraordinary.
There was a great piece in
the New York Times on Monday
that you probably saw that kind
of talks about all of those
who never get a moment of
silence on the House floor.
But what's the point?
What is the point?
And so that's what we've been doing.
And we've now posted a
wall outside my office.
If you looked at the number
of people who died since 1970
from gun violence and compared
it to the Vietnam Memorial,
it would be two and
a half miles long.
It would have 400,000 names on it.
And there were, I think, 41
mass shootings in April --
more than there are
days of the month.
We had a lot of fun with this.
We did a whole series
on the price is wrong.
And it was about spare
parts in the military budget
and how much money is wasted
in the spare parts budget.
We have a DLA -- it's a
defense logistics agency --
it's like the big Home
Depot that they're supposed
to get their spare parts from.
But then they end up buying
them from contractors.
And so an elbow, a plastic HVC
elbow that would cost a dollar
at Home Depot we paid $80 for.
So this is one of those efforts
where we did the price is wrong.
How much does this really cost
and how much did we pay for it?
This one, you may wonder why I have
a vodka bottle on the House floor.
I was walking into the Speaker's
Lobby with this bottle of vodka,
a steak that had been
cooked, and a phony jar
of caviar on a silver plate.
And the parliamentarian came
up to me and said, "Ms. Speier,
we can't have demonstrations
on the floor."
I said, "How is this
a demonstration?"
Or an exhibition -- he
used some term of art.
And he says, "It's the silver tray."
I said okay.
So I took the items
on the House floor.
And you're going to probably
wonder what I was doing here.
Well, I was offended because we were
about to cut the food
stamp budget by 50%.
But just that month a number of
my colleagues had taken trips --
codels -- around the world and were
dining in Russia on vodka and caviar
and in Argentina on steaks.
And I thought that on the one
hand, you know, it's okay for them
to be -- have their food
stamp program, but we're going
to take food away from the
poorest in our country.
So this one, I don't know if
it's going to be able to play,
but this got to be kind of funny.
And there was a piece that was
a parody that was done on it.
Thank you, [inaudible]
California 14 we have
about 4,000 families
who are on food stamps.
But some of my colleagues have
thousands and thousands more.
Yet they somehow feel
like crusaders,
like heroes when they
vote to cut food stamps.
Some of these same members
travel to foreign countries
under the guise of
official business.
They dine at lavish restaurants,
eating steak, vodka,
and even caviar.
They receive money to do this.
That's right, they don't pay
out-of-pocket for these meals.
Let me give you a few examples.
One member was given $127.41 a day
for food on his trip to Argentina.
He probably had a fair
amount of steak.
Another member was
given $3,588 for food
and lodging during a
six-day trip to Russia.
He probably drank a
fair amount of vodka
and probably even had some caviar.
That particular member has
21,000 food stamp recipients
in his district.
One of those people who is on
food stamps could live a year
on what this Congressman spent
on food and lodging for six days.
Another 20 members made a
trip to Dublin, Ireland.
They got $166 a day for food.
These members didn't pay a dime.
They received $50, $100, almost $200
for a single meal only
for themselves.
Yet for them the idea of helping
fellow Americans spend less
than $5 a day makes
their skin crawl.
The families of veterans,
of farmers, of the disabled,
of the working poor are
not visible to them --
not even when they are
their own constituents.
Last week a man named Ron
Shaich wrote in an article
on his LinkedIn page
about food stamps.
Ron is the founder, chairman,
and CEO of Panera Bread.
In this article Ron admitted that
despite wanting to fight poverty
and hunger in America, he
really didn't know what it was
like to be truly hungry.
And so this week Ron is
taking the SNAP challenge --
the millionaire food mogul
is living on $4.50 a day.
I've taken the SNAP
challenge in the past,
and I can tell you it is
a horrible experience.
You think about food constantly.
You are always hungry.
But those on food stamps
live on $4.50 every day --
not for one week -- for
long into their future.
That is soul crushing.
Historically food stamps have
been part of the farm bill.
It's that same bill that
26 corporate farmers
who remain nameless
get $1 million each
in subsidizes meant
for real farmers.
The taxpayers are giving $7 billion
per year to large agribusiness,
yet Republicans feel SNAP
programs cost us too much money.
They want to cut it.
Mr. Speaker, I can stand
here and say that my point is
about saving food stamps
from cuts -- that's true.
But my larger point is about us as a
country, as a society, as neighbors.
I'm a member of the
least-productive Congress
in the history of this country.
I'm ashamed of that.
To be honest, if the federal
government shut down for a couple
of weeks as we keep hearing,
would [inaudible] even notice?
When a government of the people or
for the people becomes a government
in spite of the people, then
who are we really serving?
If we refuse to take care of
those who are the most vulnerable
at a tiny fraction of the costs
of, say, our defense budget,
don't we cease to be
true public servants?
Ron Shaich is putting
himself in the worn-out shoes
of 48 million fellow Americans.
I'm ready to do the same again.
I wonder how many of my
Republican colleagues would want
to cut food stamps if they
had taken the SNAP challenge?
After all, that means no more
steak, no more caviar or vodka.
Based on these members'
eating habits,
I wonder if they could survive.
I yield back.
So there was just one last
one I wanted to show you.
There it is.
So this is another way that
you can make public policy.
This is a bill I introduced,
never had a hearing,
never got voted on but became law.
And that's how sometimes
we get things done,
by introducing the bill,
others recognize the importance
of doing something about it.
This was a bill introduced to
tell the Treasury Department
to stop minting the dollar coins
because no one was using them
and we were spending $300
million a year to store them.
So I introduced the bill and three
months later the Treasury Department
decided that they were
going to stop minting them.
Okay.
>> Colleen Shogan: Perfect.
Our last question today is
just a general question:
What's next for you, both
personally or professionally?
What can we expect
from you in the future?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: So
my life has never been one
that you could plan or predict.
I was 29 years from the
first time I ran for Congress
to the second time
I ran for Congress.
That's a record in this Congress.
I never had any intentions
of coming back to Congress.
Once I left, I was done.
So I don't know what's next.
We can't, I think,
plan out our lives
because there's always
something that will intervene.
So I'm going to just
continue to make mischief.
>> Colleen Shogan: Okay, terrific.
We can now take some
questions from the audience.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: That's
a very good question --
does it help me kind
of respond to veterans?
Absolutely it does.
I mean, I was on an airstrip under
fire for a couple of minutes,
and yet, our men and women who
serve are there day in, day out,
enduring the most incredible
atrocities.
I spent the night -- and you can
see where Congressman Ryan has kind
of filtered through my life --
I spent the night at
a homeless shelter
in my district a couple years ago.
And around 1:00 a.m. -- I'd
been talking to lots of people.
And it was very edifying.
Because the first people I met
were two people who were working.
One was working at Safeway in the
bakery and the other was working
in the warehouse at Office Max.
And working people living
in a homeless shelter.
But about 1:00 a.m.
this one gentleman comes
up to me and tells me his story.
He was a veteran, he got out, he
had a six-figure job at Oracle,
and then he hit a downward
spiral -- drugs and alcohol --
and was last at the rehab program
at Menlo Park in my district.
He looked me in the eye and he said,
"You have no idea what my
country forced me to do in Iraq."
And we don't.
We have no idea.
So post-traumatic stress is real.
For that nanosecond that I was
under fire, I had repercussions
of it for a very long time.
Twenty-one gun salutes
would send me into orbit.
Firecrackers going off
would make me twitch.
So it is a very real result of war.
And, you know, we now know that,
what, 30% or 40% of those returning
from war are suffering
from PTSD [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Well,
there's so many stories.
I mean, and I experience
them all the time.
You know, I'll be at the grocery
store and people will come up to me
and thank me because [inaudible]
after the Great Recession hit.
What do you do when 10% of your
population is out of a job?
So we started posting these
job hunters boot camps
that were not just job fairs
with the opportunity to match
with an employer, but also
how do you retrain yourself?
If you're middle-aged,
you lost your job,
how do you avoid the
discrimination that's so obvious?
How do you use social media?
So I've had lots of people
that have come up to me
and said, "I finally got a job."
And you could see that their lives
-- that they had been reborn.
Or people with mortgages
were [inaudible].
I keep a helmet on the shelf in my
office that was signed by a number
of victims -- survivors -- of
sexual assault in the military.
And that's just a constant reminder
that the work is really important
that we do and that sometimes it's
a huge boulder that we're pushing
up a hill and we never think
we're going to get it up.
I mean, that's a great example with
sexual assault in the military.
I mean, yes, it should be taken
out of the chain of command.
That's what my legislation would do.
But we have gotten a number
of significant improvements
to the Uniform Code of Military
Justice in the last five years
by some of the amendments
that we have gotten
into the law that's
improved the status of those
who are sexually assaulted.
I continue to be concerned
about whistleblowers
and the retaliation
that they endure.
And we're dealing with that kind of
issue in the intelligence committee.
So those are all issues that I
feel very strongly about and intend
to be here to see them through.
>> Colleen Shogan: We have
one question over here.
Oh no, no, no.
You over here and then over here.
>> Hi. I want to thank
you for your work
on sexual assault in the military.
And I'm wondering if you
had done any studies --
and this is on behalf
on a cousin of mine --
on the link between sexual
assault in the military
and our epidemic of
military suicides?
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: I
have not done any studies,
but I know that there
is some link to that.
Because you can just see the
downward spiral that takes place.
What I was astonished by as
I got to meet more and more
of these survivors is
particularly the women were legacy.
I mean, their fathers and
grandfathers and uncles had all been
in the military and this
was a family commitment.
And because it's an all volunteer
military now, these are people
who join because they want
to make a career of it.
And because they're sexually
assaulted and they report it,
they basically lose their jobs.
They're labeled with
personality disorder.
Imagine a DD214 that you then
take to a future employer
and it says you have a
personality disorder.
I mean, that's what they were doing.
So you could see how their
lives could easily unravel
and that suicide would be, you know,
their alternative to continuing
to live in a state
that was unacceptable.
But I have not actually done any
kind of study on that [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: Well,
my schedule is not typical.
I don't know what typical is.
You know, the very first campaign I
ran for after I lost for Congress,
I was running for the board
of supervisors and I was told
"Make this call, you're going
to get a $250 contribution."
And I hemmed and hawed
and then I made the call
and I got $100 contribution.
So I've never been good at this.
So I'm not the type that
will get on the phone
and just raise money
for the most part.
I will do an event in my district.
And people will come to the event.
But I would say in terms
of doing events back here,
maybe four hours a month?
Not what I would say is typical.
>> Colleen Shogan: Other questions?
Yes, right here [inaudible].
>> Last question.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Last question, okay.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Rep. Jackie Speier:
That's a very good question.
When we were about to make the trip,
the State Department kept
telling us, "You know,
we can't force Jim
Jones to meet with you.
You have to get an
invitation on your own.
We have visited the commune.
They seem very happy.
Everyone seems to be
glad to be there."
Meanwhile, you know, we've already
had some defectors who have come
through the councilor office.
We had a briefing in the
embassy in Georgetown a day
or two before we actually
went to Jonestown.
And they provided us
with a slide show.
Now mind you, the slide
show had a picture
of our two councilor officers
with Jim Jones arm in arm.
What kind of message
was that sending?
So I was pretty critical of State in
terms of their lack of recognition
that they had a responsibility
to follow up on so many
of these inquiries that had been
made about people being held there
against their will, Social Security
checks being improperly handled.
And I believe that the political
trumped the councilor function
in that regard.
And bauxite was a very
important component.
We were importing a lot of
bauxite from Guyana at the time.
And I think those interests trumped
the interests of Americans citizen
that were being held
there against their will.
>> Colleen Shogan: Please
join me in thanking --
>> Rep. Jackie Speier:
I have one more comment.
>> Colleen Shogan: Sorry.
I should have had known.
Right? I should have learned.
>> Rep. Jackie Speier: I just want
to leave you with you've got a sense
of how my life has meandered,
and I didn't touch on the loss
of my husband when I was
pregnant with our second child.
But it was another traumatic
experience in my life.
But I've learned something
that's very important.
And the quotation I want
to share with you is one
that I hope you will keep in mind.
"Life should not be a journey
with the intention of arriving
in a well-preserved body
at the end of your life,
but rather you should be totally
worn out, totally used up --
martini in one hand,
chocolate in the other,
screaming, 'Woo hoo, what a ride.'"
>> Colleen Shogan: All right.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.